hot breath seinfeld told you to move
around more on stage do you
do you bring that advice to all your
gigs or just the larger ones
now i do it in all of them why the hell
not because
i wouldn't do it but when he told me
that i was like uh what the hell this
guy's old-fashioned he's you know he's
out of touch
and i did it and my set went from a
b-minus to an a-plus
so he was right and i i'm glad i
took his advice and i'm glad i applied
it because why the hell not if it works
in a theater
it'll work on a club so what did you
change i'm not jumping around
like what did you change everything
i used to walk out plant my feet at a on
a theater stage and just deliver my joke
standing there
and they went well but you walk out and
you walk all the way to one side walk
all the way they'll do like a chris rock
thing
start saying the n word everything and
uh you will
that crowd can't take their eyes off of
you and they're mesmerized and now now
they're so mesmerized that they're
engaged more and listening more
so they're going to hear every joke
every word every punch
so that equals more laughs